harris who has written this book its
title Ben Bernanke's said the Federal
Reserve after Greenspan you right mr.
Harris that the there's not a lot
written book wise about this relatively
new Fed Chairman you might be the first
or one of the first but I look together
explain his role first in all of the
financial market situations right now
how powerful is he and what is his
thought process well he and the Treasury
secretary really run the show in terms
of dealing with these financial crises
and the it the split of power is very
arbitrary in a way because it depends on
what particular tool they're trying to
bring to bear on the particular crisis
the Fed mainly operates through lending
up from its balance sheet to financial
institutions the treasury by providing a
taxpayer support to financial
institutions so they both play an
important role here and his a background
his name is Benjamin Shalom Bernanke
Ellis where he came from where he was
educated how he became fed chairman's
get around yeah so so Bernanke is a
academic for much of his career taught
at a number of universities the last
teaching job at Princeton and he spent
time as a fed governor so he got a
little bit of training on the job I'll
be before becoming fed chairman and he's
kind of unusual because it's hard these
days to find an academic economist that
can do the practical job of running
policy because most of these guys spend
their time writing high math and
statistics don't really look at
practical issues he was a little
different I think then a lot of the
other big-name macroeconomist he
actually looked at some of the big
practical questions that drive Fed
policy did he have a lot of support
coming in from the Senate what was that
period like two years ago well I think
the people because the the academic
community and the Business Economics
community supported the idea that
Bernanke he did he did have strong
support he got through the Senate
confirmation hearings pretty easily
actually
the sense was that this is a guy who has
the right training for the job he makes
sense as the Fed Chairman what's your
critique of n plus and perhaps minus
well on the plus side you know he's been
dealt a very tough hand here I mean the
Fed is facing a credit crisis a housing
crisis and for a while they're very high
oil prices all three of these shocks
hitting right on top of each other and
the Fed has managed to avoid a severe
recession you still have a very bad
economy you've got a lot of problems
still in the capital markets but he has
avoided you know an outright recession
so he's been an active done an active
job of fighting a potential downturn the
negatives for him have been on
communication that tie the Fed at times
has seemed kind of awkward in the way
they've talked to the markets policies
seem to go on again off again at time so
it's it's it's been more in the
communications side where the feds had
problems rather than the actual policy
actions phone numbers on the bottom of
the screen for our guest he is Ethan
Harris author of Ben Bernanke said the
Federal Reserve after Greenspan here's
another look at the book will get to
your phone calls just as soon as they
start coming in How well do you know mr.
Bernanke I don't know that well I mean I
prefer meet him professionally at
various meetings who talked him over the
years he's this isn't a book where I'm
like an investigative reporter sitting
down and and just killing him up for
questions it's more kind of the how Wall
Street economist might through the Fed
Chairman what's the personality
comparison between mr. Bernanke and his
predecessor Alan Greenspan what do
people talk about well I mean the dip
they're both introverted personalities i
think but Greenspan I think over the
years became much more comfortable in
the limelight I think he enjoyed being
in Washington and kind of in this in the
center of power I think for Bernanke
he's more happy kind of being in the
background you know working hard
thinking about the economy working with
the team of economist
so he's a little less of a celebrity I
would say them than Alan Greenspan what
did you make of yesterday decision not
to increase rates to cover is I have not
you've got not to cut rates i should say
well i think that ultimately the fed is
going to have to cut interest rates this
this the capital markets are in severe
distress there's clearly going to be a
more tough times ahead the economy is
very weak I think well I would have
liked them to cut rates the other day I
think eventually they will have to cut
rates further one more point about our
guests before we go to calls because he
didn't know Ethan Harris is a chief us
economist for Lehman Brothers which of
course has been huge in the news here's
the New York Post headline today British
feast on a lehman fire sale Barclays
striking a deal to buy most of the
bankrupt Lehman Brothers about two
billion dollars what is this story mean
to you well personally but what's your
assessment of what's going on at Lehman
well when you only talk about on a
personal level because they really
shouldn't be talking about it and a
professional level this is that you know
there'd be a kind of a violation of my
ethics but on a personal level I mean
this is a very painful event I mean
people kind of think of Wall Street
people as tough skinned people but you
know this is a little bit like breaking
up a family when you have a have a
bankruptcy like this and a lot of people
of course have lost huge amounts of
wealth and climbing taneously lost their
job and so that kind of double hit you
know it's been quite painful Franklin
topic here is a ben bernanke the book
here written by Ethan Harris our first
call was from Massachusetts winchendon
mass go ahead please yes sir I would
like to know first of all is your book
readable for average American housewife
can I read your book and come away with
some understanding number one that's my
first question the second one is I keep
hearing completely opposite opinions we
have wrong economy we have a weak
economy
ah when my husband and I were married 28
years ago we bought a house in Oregon we
got we felt we had a steal of a deal
because we got an interest rate of ten
percent and at the time the interest
rates were fifteen percent and you were
required to put down at least ten if not
twenty percent thanks to questions there
why don't we take the very reverse order
good or bad as the economy well i mean
the the economy is is is quite weak out
there i mean what what i think of what
people are talking about is that the
economy relative to the shocks the
economy done okay but to say the economy
is doing well i think is kind of wishful
thinking i mean the economy is in what
I've been calling a slow-motion
recession gradual job loss gradual rise
in the unemployment rate this is this is
a pretty tough economy in terms of
readability yeah I think so actually you
know one of the things I've done with
the book because I've really tried to
make it readable I want I want to appeal
to a broad audience this isn't a very
technical book it's written but it is
serious book it's an attempt to say okay
listen what do you really need to know
about the Fed as an average person is an
average investor and I try to have a
little fun with this I mean there are
some believe it or not there's some
amusing things about what goes on the
fed and in fed history but also you know
really try to bring it to readers with
in a friendly kind of way so I think I
think that it is a broadly readable book
our guests at a PhD in economics from
columbia university also worked at the
federal reserve bank of new york for
nine years Ethan Harris has taken a call
now from New Bedford Massachusetts
welcome hi I'm a question I'm a disabled
vet and I've been appealing v8 for 34
years and I can't get anywhere and in a
wheelchair what's going to happen to
these poor kids that are coming home now
what are they going to end up with and
what's bush you're gonna do just make
more money to have a dollar go down
further though any thoughts Oh
well I mean I certainly share concerns
about you know veterans coming back
after serving the country and I think
that this is something that it was
important on a personal level it's not
something I'm an expert on but I think
it is important to support the vets and
when they especially people who come
back with you no injuries from the war
Canton Ohio welcome to the program yes I
have a question for mr. Harris stories
mr. Harris did was hit the economic goal
of the day has been all these crazy by
off that we have to have with AIG and
and etc set of Fannie Mae and Freddie
Mac what should give them its role in
this you know I see us committing as a
nation to build these companies up but
yet I see these executives walking out
with these parachutes which have beyond
the realm of the imagination of the
American people and I'm I feel somewhat
disconcerted with that yeah well you
know this is a one of the toughest
things in terms of policymaking how do
you balance the bailing out of
institutions versus rewarding bad
behavior and I think that the the Fed
and the Treasury generally have taken
kind of a middle course here in other
words try to hold back from committing
taxpayer dollars but but we have to
remember that if they stand back and
allow these big financial institutions
to collapse the cost to taxpayers is
going to be much bigger because the
economy is going to be so bad you can
end up that even even bigger budget
deficits so it's it's a very tough
choice they have to they have to make
balance these concerns and the one of
the things i would say that clearly
there needs to be rethinking of
regulation and you know to do
the frequency and size of these crises
and that will go a long way from
protecting taxpayer dollars because I
have some sympathy with you it's going
to have to explain the structure of the
said we know the Chairman and Bernanke
here's some of the other members so five
total on the Fed well normally you'd
have you'd have seven members of the
Board of Governors many of 12 regional
presidents that each take a turn voting
in their their policy meetings but right
now they're a little undermanned at the
Fed that's been kind of a chronic issue
with the Fed they don't have a full
group of Governors right and what does
that mean well it makes work a little
harder for the rest of the gang there i
mean the the Fed is a pretty broad
oversight in terms of consumer affairs
in terms of banking system in terms of
monetary policy and international
affairs so they really need to have
their full complement of governors but
they've been kind of hung up in Congress
periodically and right now they are
short-handed then back to Ben Bernanke
himself trans New York Times has the
story about AIG yesterday they talk
about Treasury secretary Paulson and Fed
Chairman Bernanke convening a meeting
with House and Senate leaders on the
hill last night about 630pm who
explained the rescue plan they emerged
just after seven-thirty p.m. with mr.
Paulson and mr. Bernanke looking grim
some of the headlights chested members
of the leadership were stunned but
resigned to all of this it reminds me to
ask you about Ben Bernanke's
relationship further with the hill so he
gets approved a couple of years ago
what's his current relationship like
when he goes back and forth for visits
well I don't you know I think I know
better kind of his relationship with the
wall street and kind of the general
public but i think that the that it's
hard for everyone to be happy an
environment like this where you've got
all these problems emerging on his watch
is fed chairman so it wouldn't be
surprising if there's a growing negative
sentiment about this but what we need to
remember with this is that the the
genesis of the problems the Fed is
facing right now
came before his chairmanship and and
perhaps if we're going to blame the
federal reserve for some of these
problems actually Alan Greenspan is
probably deserves more blame than Ben
Bernanke now with that said a lot of
what's going on in the capital markets
was very unpredictable I certainly never
expected things to get as tough as they
are and so in a sense you know we're
just going through one of those terrible
convulsions in the markets and it's
ending up requiring some pretty
aggressive policy responses moving on to
Long Island New York now good wing good
morning thank you she spent for doing
what you do mr. Harris you just totally
took the words right out of my mouth
when you said about mr. Greenspan that's
pretty much what I wanted to ask you and
get to that that's what a point of view
was how much of this is mr. Greenspan to
blame I mean and there's so many areas
that you can blame for the weak economy
immigration how much does the legal
immigration have to do with this but I
mean yeah how about mr. Greenspan how
much culpability does he have in this
bad economy right now well you know one
of the things that again one of the
tough things about being a policy maker
which I have sympathy for because I
worked for the first half of my career
at the Federal Reserve Bank of New York
you know it's the toughest thing to do
as a policy makers to figure out whether
there's a bubble or not in the capital
markets and then what to do about it you
know the feds got a lot of things to
deal with they're trying to manage the
economy and inflation and when there's
potential bubble in the asset markets
that just adds another layer of concern
I i think that the Fed should have been
a little tighter with monetary policy
when the housing market was looking very
bubbly when he had a big increase in the
number of people who describe themselves
as investors in the housing market when
he had a very aggressive mortgages being
made to many different borrowers and had
huge price increases in some of the
region's and so it seemed to me that
in 2004-2005 there really was evidence
that the housing market was in a bubble
and what the Fed should have done then i
think is try to not not pop the bubble
because that would have required a super
aggressive attack by the Fed and that
would have hurt the economy but they
could have leaned against the bubble it
could have raised interest rates a
little faster could have talked about
concerns about the bubble instead of
kind of denying the bubble so in that
respect I think Alan Greenspan should
take some of the blame but you know
remember financial crises bubbles have
been a part of history you know no
central bank is immune is consumer a'n't
and you know there's only a limited
amount policymakers can do to stop that
palm beach florida you're on with Ethan
Harris well thank you for taking my call
I certainly and thank God every night
for c-span at least we get to hear the
other side even though it may be tainted
and I really appreciate you and the
people who sit in your position because
it's hard to to be so fair under such
terrible conditions that we have I'd
like to address a couple of things that
the gentleman who's talking about his
book i'm sorry that i missed the name
Ethan Harris he's in harris and the mr.
Harris question was asked and it
appeared to me that you address part of
it but not be the whole thing's I have
two things I want to address because
when we bail out these private companies
who are there for profits it appears to
me that the stopper of the stockholders
and the people in the corporation are
there for the profit but the American
people are there for the lost
we're in for the loss totally but we're
not for the profit and so when when the
parachute has to be filled I think it
should be filled with the same hot air
that the CEO gave us about how the
companies were doing well until suddenly
they weren't the other thing that I want
to discuss is this business of lowering
the interest rate I suppose that's done
so that the banks and everyone can have
better access to money not necessarily
is people like me but banks and other
people that are are in a position to get
big amounts of money let's hear from
Ethan Harris yeah you know again I mean
the the problem is i think a in
certainly in this recent events a big
part of the problem was a failure to
regulate adequately you know a lot of
the problems in capital markets right
now come back to the subprime mortgage
market which frankly certainly the 20-20
hindsight and even at the time seemed to
be way too aggressive in terms of
offering easy easy credit and so if you
can kind of void those of those excesses
you you have a better chance of not
having to have a bailout what I would
say though is remember that with these
with these downturns in these financial
firms it isn't true that nobody gets
hurt in the business you know you've had
massive layoffs at these companies
you've had stock prices go effectively
20 and companies and so there's been
some big losses for people so they are
bearing pain and it's not a completely a
one-way bet for for these companies but
and the other issue is you know do you
want to allow the full effect of the
collapse in the financial system on the
economy or do you want to try and and at
least modify or limit that damage so i
think that the
the practical thing to do as a
policymaker is to have a bailout and but
to do it in a way where the people who
took the risks feel some real pain and
so they have an incentive in the future
to try and be a little more careful
about what they're doing but I think
stepping back and just letting the
financial system collapse I think would
be a serious mistake now you also talked
about the lowering of interest rates for
the Fed there's no magic here but when
when the fed cuts interest rates and
something I talk about in the book you
know the funds rate which is the
interest rate the Fed controls doesn't
affect individuals in any way if
something's a lending rate between banks
but when you lower the funds rate it has
a ripple effect through the capital
markets right now the capital markets
are not functioning very well so as the
Fed lowers interest rates it's not
having the usual beneficial effects but
over time as you keep interest rates low
eventually it should restore house
values and growth in the housing market
it should restore the stock market it
should make us products more competitive
and trade there's a transmission into
broader assets that benefit the economy
and therefore indirectly help average
Americans so the feds efforts to lower
interest rates while they're not very
successful right now because of all the
capital market problems now eventually
will help provide the economy and after
all that's what really matters is
getting the economy going and stopping
the job losses Activia the process of a
Fed Chairman this particular Fed
Chairman Ben Bernanke mentioned he's an
academic specializing is rogen about the
Great Depression what might he be
applying to current Dave situation from
his at past studies I mean one of the
interesting things with Bernanke and it
was kind of a fortuitous is that if you
look at his research as an academic he
looked he studied the Great Depression
very closely he studied the Japanese
deflation in the 1990s Japan had a
terrible banking crisis in a long period
of weak growth
he's also studied the relationship
between credit and the economy which
obviously is very relevant today with
all the problems in the markets for
credit so his training as an academic
actually applies to his current job as
Fed Chairman what did he learn from
these events well one of the things he
learned is that it's very important to
not allow the banking system to collapse
I mean the if you go back to the Great
Depression the fundamental cause of the
Great Depression wasn't the stock market
crash which kind of started things off
it was the collapse of the banking
system you can't allow the banking
system to collapse if there's no banking
system there's no credit and you end up
in a new deep depression and so his you
know his reading of history and writing
about the history of that episode I
think has a big impact on his thinking
today as he looks at the banking system
running into the serious problems it
gets back to this issue that a number of
your callers have brought up which is
you know why should they be bailing out
these financial institutions and the
answer is if you don't bail them out
which is what happened in the 1930s and
they really do go down in a serious way
you've got a horrible economy and so
it's an unfortunate thing that it's a
little bit unfair certainly to reward
financial institutions for their
mistakes but the alternative is worse
and that's that's that's what they think
Bernanke understands so we talk about
academic training know how to what
extent does instinct come the feeling
that a Fed chair might have about
conditions in what to do about them how
much does that play into all this well I
mean you know being a Fed Chairman is a
pretty difficult job and you've got a
very complicated financial market
problem on your hands and the economy is
very hard to predict right now and it is
true that you know as a new Fed Chairman
there's a learning process and so that's
being done in under the fire right now
for Ben Bernanke it's it would probably
would have been a little happier having
a couple years to break in on the job
before having to face so all these
difficult
but yeah there's definitely an art as
well as a science to being central
banker back to calls for Ethan Harris
enosburg Vermont thank you for waiting
hi there good morning Paul when my
condolences to mr. irons mr. Harris you
know I have a comment into question and
I'll make it very brief I think it's
obvious that institutionalized cutouts
like Fannie Mae and Freddie back have
been used for political bribery much
like the five billion dollars we send to
Israel is sent back a support for
politicians and support for false
Christian Broadcasting my question on
sep tember night the deputy Treasury
secretary Jeremiah and Norton said that
private control of an institution with a
public mission didn't make sense how
would you explain this apparent
contradiction Lisa V the public
Republican mantra of privatizing control
of every public institution thank you
yeah I mean I think they're there is a
concern you know if you talk to this
been a concern of the Federal Reserve
has had as they look at that the two big
mortgage companies Fannie Mae and
Freddie Mac and that you want to have a
clear distinction between public
companies and private companies and you
don't want to have an institution that
has an implicit guarantee on debt on its
debt by the federal government because
it'll the company will then act as
though it has a guaranteed and it's
really not a good model to have this
hybrid type of situation and I think
that it is a sense in the economics
community that that's probably not a
good idea you know you want to be very
separate one of public institutions with
public purposes that are accountable to
politicians and into taxpayers many want
to private institutions that are
accountable to their stockholders and
you don't really want to have the two
commingled certainly not in a big way
generally Tulsa Oklahoma you're on the
air go ahead salsa a couple of just real
quick questions regarding do you think
how significant was the
steel prices going up and the oil prices
going up and in relation to people not
being able to pay for their own and also
when are we going to start thinking
about people really paying for things
rather than just borrowing money against
things and there's a seems to me we've
lost sight of the long-term what really
means we just by washing machines on
time or things that we could really
change your life and now we just buy
every little thing on time thanks yeah I
mean I think those are both very good
questions I mean on the i think that the
rise in oil prices and other commodity
prices has been a big factor in
weakening the economy making it harder
for people to pay their mortgages it's
added a new layer of stress into the
economy and into the housing market and
so it's actually very the best news
we've had on the economy in the last
year has been that finally oil prices
have to come to gravity and are coming
back down to earth still very high but
at least a coming back down a bit and so
that's been a big factor in hurting the
economy it's the one really positive
thing I see going forward that we do
think that oil price will continue to
ease and that will show up over time in
lower gasoline prices in terms of buying
on credit I agree that the the average
u.s. household has gotten a little too
dependent and credit not saving for down
payments you know buying everything on
credit that is reversing and I think we
will see a little bit more thriftiness
of American consumer in the coming
decade return to more normal kind of
saving behind patterns I don't think
it's going to happen overnight but it
does feel like the US consumer got
overextended their needs to pull back a
bit over time and that will that will
occur I think it will have a more frugal
US consumer in the next decade you
mentioned earlier your book is pretty
readable in your view to the average
person but speak more to the average
person about the feds actions when they
see these headlines and they see things
flashing across TVs
greens about the set about ben bernanke
how directly does it affect them what
should they look for on a personal level
well I mean the Fed is you know is a
good barometer of what's going on in the
economy and in the markets and it's it's
very important from the average person's
point of view that the Fed succeeds
frankly that their their efforts to
revive the economy work and and people
want to I think pay close attention as
they kind of watch their own investments
to whether they believe that the Fed and
is able to revive growth in the economy
and get things going again so I think
with that it's it the Fed is a is a very
vital to the economic performance
washington DC a good morning good
morning I just wanted to say please two
things I have a come in but before I do
what you please give the title of that
book one more time now I would win I
don't like my title being repeated
here's the title hold on a sec viewer
Ben Bernanke's fed the Federal Reserve
after Greenspan Ethan Harris is the
author needs with us thank you now so
you will remember the full do economics
cleary or thoughts or comment yeah food
allegedly do you think that this is a
voodoo economics coming to fruition 40
years later well voodoo economics is it
was a phrase i guess that george bush
senior invented in as a criticism of
ronald reagan before they paired up as
president and vice president and the
idea was that you know tax cuts would
have a big stimulus impact on the
economy and ultimately pay for
themselves my view on this is that in
the economics profession is the general
acceptance that all else equal you lower
taxes of better than higher taxes taxes
distort behavior the discourage activity
there general you don't want high taxes
but you also don't want high budget
deficits so it's not a good idea to cut
taxes
and have huge budget deficits as a
result and so I think there's a general
sense in the economics profession that
you know the best thing to do is have a
discipline budget keep the get rid of
the earmarks keep spending under control
have programs that are effective on the
spending side and then fund that with
taxes don't run NASA budget deficits so
I do think that there'd been there's
been a little bit over selling of the
idea of tax cuts as a solution for
everything because of tax cuts come with
deficits than there a bad idea as an
analyst how do you rate the performance
of the Bush administration in the
current Congress autonomic Lee yeah i
mean i would i would say they'd been
they do i would give them a mediocre
grade we've seen the budget deficits
come back in a big way they're going to
be under tremendous budget pressure in
the next 20 years as the baby boom
generation retires and starts to take
Social Security and Medicare benefits we
are in a period where there should be a
lot of discipline in the budget to get
us ready for that very tough environment
in the next 20 years but instead what
we've seen is a complete lack of
discipline on the spending side and
multiple tax cuts it's really i think
it's i don't think this is the right way
to go i think we want we want too much
better discipline in terms of fiscal
balls and moving on to Wheeling West
Virginia now for Ethan Harris Wow
program thank you excellent okay my Carl
tore up to question first of all I'm old
enough to know that what happened in mid
eighteen S&L crisis it I remembered that
well and I remember that automakers said
that they can do everything possible so
they were not just repeated again and
and they're going to put safeguards in
place and so forth and nowadays I see
the same thing happening again and I was
wondering what has changed to that I
mean how do we know that at this point
in time whatever safety things they put
in place is not going to be happen again
10 years from now much
seeing the same problem in the bigger
they mess the second question I'm sorry
is that what kind of the guidelines of
the policymaker used to decide who to
bail out and who's not to be a lot and
why wasn't even brother bailed out
because to me they were almost very
similar situation as the others and if
they are supposed to business of bailing
out they wouldn't that kind of trumped a
free market ideals that that the market
do whatever it does i mean the excuse
that well it's going to be worse than
it's better to go with the bad than the
worse it's kind of it's kind of an
analogy that this is kind of perpetuated
the end of free markets thank you our
guest is chief us economist for lehman
brothers or why not your company why
other companies unwell i mean it's
something i've been pondering is there
is what do you want to say I hello I
want to act like a politician here dodge
the question um the part of it has to do
with too-big-to-fail notion that if the
bigger financial institution is the more
their failure could topple the financial
markets in the economy so I think that
that probably has something to do with
what's happened here and that's about as
far as I want to go in that question and
that that I think has been an element of
a lot of the decisions we've seen in
terms of the you know avoiding another
kind of SNL crisis you know I do agree
that this has been you know it feels
like deja vu here with the capital
markets and what you need is a what's
happened is though they're never who
hasn't been fundamental regulatory
reform over the years even though
everyone agrees that that's that's a
good idea so er I I think that what you
need is sensible regulation that doesn't
over regulate the markets but addresses
a lot of the holes in the current system
a lot of the overlap and that that will
then mitigate future crises you're not
going to eliminate financial market
crisis I mean that this is a fact of
history but you can
reduce the frequency and severity by
having sensible regulatory structure and
you want a regulatory structure that
allows growth in the industry but also
sensible regulation there is one take on
why not Lehman Brothers in terms of the
bailout if you look at the christian
science monitor today the sunny side of
Wall Street is their editorial but
there's a little passage in here in the
editorial that says one likely reason
Treasury secretary Paulson didn't did
not rescue Lehman Brothers last week was
that the investment bank had six months
since the collapse of rival Bear Stearns
to fix its mistake of over borrowing to
buy risky mortgage-related securities it
didn't know the worth of his assets you
think well I think that the don't want
to comment directly on Lehman but if you
look at the one of the problems in the
capital markets right now is a lack of
trust a lack of ability to price assets
that that affects every financial firm
it makes investors reluctant to invest
in companies so this is not something
unique to lehman it's a general problem
for the financial sector time for a
couple more calls for our guests odenton
Marilyn good morning good morning how
you doing fine I have two questions on
mr. Harris the first question is you
don't you neglect to answer directly the
concerns made by callers about the
enormous compensation packages for the
executives and CEOs of companies that
are failing that money could go a long
way toward fixing some of the problems
that the taxpayers are having the paper
and my second question is why can't the
government instead of giving money to
Wall Street to fix their problems just
give money directly to the taxpayer so
that they can continue it grow the
economy and keep the economy going
instead of these third-party deals that
involve fingers on Wall Street who are
robbing us blind Thanks okay well just
think just so I don't sound like a total
politician or in the compensation
packages I think it's simple and you
should get paid if you succeed you
shouldn't get paid if you fail and
that's the way compensation packages
should be designed I'm not sure that's
all
the case but you know I that's that's
the nature of things it shouldn't be the
case it's an executive it does a
terrible job running the company that
they end up making a huge amount of
money in spite of that in terms of
giving money directly to taxpayers
rather than than supporting firms we
have had that we've had 150 billion
dollar fiscal package including about a
hundred and ten billion dollar in in tax
rebates and that's helped a little bit
help boost the economy a little bit but
I think it makes sense to kind of work
from all angles that if you're going to
prevent the serious shock to the economy
here try to shore up the financial
system a bit try to get interest rates
down through easy monetary policy try to
get a little bit of stimulus in the
economy through tax cuts you could also
give aid to state so they can spend more
money to support the economy kind of try
everything to get it going we have a
serious crisis I think you have to have
many tools to deal with it Sugarloaf New
York you're on the air hi good morning
one I've got so many questions is
Benanti a student of milton friedman and
angry and because it all started with
the regulations back in when bush got
elected and the thing is that you have
two books for one book anyway the shock
doctrine by the only climb she she wrote
this and it's all coming to bed this is
a concerted effort by a big corporation
by a group of the World Bank that are
actually propelling this situation and
now everybody sits around saying that
green spin isn't responsible he worked
hand in hand with the President to
deregulate the banks and Wall Street why
isn't that me in court up in a hearing
course something because he's connected
with this philosophy and these groups
like Milton Friedman who's passed on
already thank God thanks
sir harris well one thing I would say in
the regulatory front which i think is
important is that and this again gets
back to the the genesis of the problem
in the markets and that is the way that
the mortgage industry was regulated
coming into this period was met was very
ineffective it was a leftover of a
different era where you had many
different regulators regulating
different kinds of lenders it created
confusion it created a lack of
accountability in terms of who really
was taking care of the market and that I
think will change going forward you want
to want an effective regulator that you
know doesn't Fort innovation but does
you know prevent you know things like
option arms and some of the other that
would be where you get a mortgage that
you choose your payment each month
rather than actually of a fixed payment
that those kind of things I don't think
makes sense I think for the there are
many consumers you don't really
understand the risk they're taking when
they take those kind of mortgages out so
the I think you do need a regulator more
organized regulatory structure that that
you know has a better it keeps a better
eye on what's going on in terms of the
mortgage market any other myths or
misperceptions you want to bring up
regarding the Fed or the current
chairman of previous chairman yeah I
mean you know people have a there's a
lot of negative views out there around
the said as though it's some kind of a
secret of institution that's trying to
manage the world for some purpose and
you know I worked at the Fed for nine
years and I didn't run into any black
black magic people there you know these
guys I mean just a just a put in
perspective these guys are accepting a
much lower paying job and they could get
out there in the private sector and
there for the most part they're a bunch
of nerdy economist just like me who
really are technocrats want to do their
job and do the best they can
and I don't I think a lot of the kind of
conspiracy notions around the Fed are
simply not true these guys my experience
with feds officials is they're very
public service oriented group last call
Halfmoon New York welcome good morning
good morning morning what well listen i
have a couple of statements here and
then i have a question and there's an
annual report that goes back to nineteen
ninety and i would like to give you a
brief on in this state this is by dr.
Quigley carroll quigley and it says the
powers of financial capitalism has
another far-reaching aim nothing less
than to create a world system of the
financial control a but in private hands
able to dominate the political system of
each country and the economy of the
world as a whole and you can research
this mr. errors on a pfn org and if
there's if there is which i think there
is a conspiracy in this country this is
a CFR report going back to nineteen
ninety and i would like to ask you uh
when you research this what would you
think about it thanks mr. Harris well I
don't I don't see any conspiracy to
control the world through financial
markets I mean remember remember the
financial markets work you've got
hundreds of big financial institutions
around the world transacting activities
this is something to to actually try and
have a cartel type arrangement where you
try to manage the world would be
extremely difficult it's just even even
though fact oil cartel doesn't work that
well at times in there a nice small
public organization so honestly I don't
see how
how the world's financial institutions
could get together and manage things
together so I you know I I don't and
I've never seen any evidence of it other
than people speculating on it Ethan
Harris is a author of this book Ben
Bernanke's fed the Federal Reserve after
Greenspan from Harvard Business press me
thank you for your time and thank you
died this morning thank you very much